did you ever put the jacuzzi on the
penthouse via the helicopter oh
[ __ ] no no we never managed to do that
so close uh so the person who actually
owned
uh the building uh said no
yeah sorry so so you bought the building
[Laughter]
yeah dawn like so instead i was like
yeah [ __ ] it like oh my god i'd have
been sick like we're gonna have a
helicopter
literally take this [ __ ] jacuzzi and
just land it on
the rooftop of uh a flat but uh yeah
they they just said nah
they just couldn't believe it they were
just like is are you serious i was like
yeah i want a jacuzzi
i wanted jacuzzi on my mind yeah for
sure
i got i got a [ __ ] jacuzzi man i
bought it so that i could jump off the
roof of my house
into the jacuzzi and that was like that
made my top 10 injury list
sure wait you surely just was in the
pool right now i dropped into a hot tub
in my butt
my butt turned into like a [ __ ] alien
from mars like [ __ ] growing out like
it was an awful injury because you hit
the cause you know how hot tubs like
they they carve out where you can sit
and your butt
landed like right to the bench yeah like
right in between
yeah yeah it was terrible man we did it
with david dobrik
[Music]
the hot tub was first yeah that was the
warm up
and if my truck record
if my track record for jumping into
shallow water isn't bad enough
now i'm trying to go for the highest
ever belly flop into
just 12 inches of pure piss
that's yeah just to throw it out there
not his own well
mostly my own we're collecting out i've
got like so far i've collected uh
28 gallons of piss
the pool that i bought for it uh has a
13-inch fill line which says takes 157
gallons to fill
wait wait surely that's not hygienic
surely there's something
something bad about that the longer you
keep it the
the grosser it gets and by the time i uh
collect 157 gallons of pe it's not gonna
be new
and fresh you're gonna jump in and just
start puking
instantly perhaps perhaps
right but that's coming off a roof and
uh and i gotta be in full skydive
position
belly nothing but belly oh my god
yeah dude